[Musique]
à
où
nous voici au bord du gouffre dans les
profondeurs de ce trou effroyable jce de
nombreux morts nombre d'habitations et
les espoirs d'une petite population qui
vivait déjà assez péniblement maintenu
depuis 24 heures sous le coup de la
panique
puis sous la menace de mahler nouveau la
petite population de saint jean vianney
n'a pas encore dénombré tous ces morts
n'a pas encore pu établir un bilan
précis de ses pertes à peine peut-on
dire pour l'instant qu environ 30
personnes ont péri pour les pertes
matérielles considérant qu'une
quarantaine de maisons
un autobus et une trentaine de voitures
ont roulé dans ce gouffre à une
profondeur inconnue les dégâts jusqu'ici
s'élèverait au moins à 2 millions et
peut-être à plus nous apprenons
dernière-heure qu'un pont se serait
écroulé ce soir sur le saguenay
il n'est pas exclu qu'une centaine
d'autres maisons construites dans le
même parfum d'argile subissent le même
sort au cours des prochains jours
turner une maison nouvelle sabine et
nous allons justement voir dans quelques
secondes une maison s'effondrer il on ne
sait pas quand ces éboulis vont prendre
fin et l'on ne sait pas quand ces
terrains argileux dont les eaux
printanières ont miné les entrailles
vont cesser de s'ouvrir pour engloutir
des maisons que des familles de faibles
revenus avaient mis tous leurs efforts à
construire
un hélicoptère de la protection civile a
recueilli à l'aube une femme qui avait
passé la nuit sur une voiture légèrement
en marge du creux de la bim
c'est semble-t-il la seule survivante
parmi les personnes qui ont roulé dans
le gouffre on a retiré jusqu'ici cinq
cadavres au bord des éboulis on a pu les
retrouver justement parce qu'il se
trouvait au bord mais les équipes de
recherche sont pas sûr du tout de
pouvoir retirer les corps des autres
victimes qui ont roulé dans l'argile
liquide avec leur maison ou leur voiture
les hommes grenouilles spécialement
équipé entreprendre est cependant de
fouiller la vase au cours des prochains
jours
un père de famille est perdu est parvenu
à me dire combien il avait crié à pleins
poumons pour faire sortir sa femme et
ses enfants de sa maison qui s'écroulait
il ne les a pas revus
monsieur laval blackburn me racontait
pour sa part avoir au pays un premier
mouvement au plus fort du tumulte et
s'être précipités au secours d'une
famille mais il a dit bien vite
rebroussé chemin
le sol se dérobait sous ses pas et nous
pourrions fournir bien d'autres
témoignages sur cette nuit dramatique où
des centaines de personnes ont
probablement connu dans un tumulte
épouvantables les moments les plus
intenses de leur vie nous allons
d'ailleurs à ce sujet entendre quelques
unes de ces personnes
[Musique]
les maisons que l'on va justement sont
parmi celles qui menacent de s'effondrer
c'est un trou d'un mille de longueur par
un quart de mille de largeur et environ
100 pieds de profondeur
[Musique]
voici quelques témoignages
quant à lumière parti l'ont attendu
cogner d'un porte à coups de pied
lyon 10 sauver vous gardez maison d'un
milieu du chemin
patron depuis le léger enfin bon on ne
peut lutter on est tous partis nu pieds
et le moment rien il est temps à martina
l'autopsié n'a ri en sortant de la
maison qu'est ce que vous avez constaté
qu'il y avait une grosse crevette en
arrière de l'auto du coup les votre
famille a pu sortir juste à temps oui
femme est sortie on
il en va de fruits retravaillé pour
n'importe qui comme ça en plus du rebond
j'étais préfet des mauvaises notes m
j'ai entendu un vrombissement jusqu'aux
studios puis j'ai dans mon mari je
deviens vite la montagne aladin est
parti dans les téléphonies sur mon frère
rob horne la bestiole ma seule c'est à
dire surtout tenu d'or qui ont entendu
un craquement l'eau là mon mari teddy
cueillir le chemin c'est qu'on lui le
clone de rentrer à la maison
on ne sortira que dans mes longs de vue
les poteaux en fixant fond c'est la
route sans concept du couteau en flammes
en langues qui la laisse bosser les
lettres celle un nom on voyait des
grands documentaires et le chacal est
tout à fait un long post annalynne du
top je tenais kalana que de nous en
sommes aux autres partis juste autant de
justesse
vers 11 heures on était h à la salle
chevalier avoir regardé l'heure de jeu
les jeunes sont arrivés il ya des on dit
et des maisons dans la rue tu as menée
dans rue harvick sens calais mais je
devais pas loin de la ville sauté dessus
de mon champ avec drogue et non de voir
ce qu'on allait voir si on pouvait pas
s'imaginer que c'était le fossé entre
les maisons d'un philippin
vue à la marsa a fallu se vend aussi
assez près pour voir mais quand on a vu
cette faute devrait environ peut-être
millepied de circonférence centaines de
pieds de profondeur
là on a vu que c'était quelque chose
maison s'écroulait à ce moment là pas
d'accord là j'ai ma maison est environ
200 pieds de la fosse puis retourner
immédiatement chez doux
javier en fabio femme se presser 1 puis
1 2 me connaissant ce que des gens des
gens soient morts autour de vous ben
disons quelqu'un d'honnête approché du
tout on attendait une clameur qui monte
est du fond du court quel genre de clame
un des gens criaient sur la bêtise et
grises d'hystérie avait donné au plus
fort de ce branle-bas autobus qui
ramenait des travailleurs de l'alc ans
ont également sombré dans l'abyme le
conducteur monsieur marcel girard eu
heureusement le sens fois d'ouvrir la
portière arrière du véhicule et tout le
monde a eu le temps de sauter demi deux
minutes plus tard
l'autobus était disparu environ 200
hommes de la protection civile de la
croix rouge de la sûreté du québec et
des services locaux de la police et des
pompiers sont placés sur un pied
d'alerté
le gouvernement québécois l'université
du québec et l'université laval ont
aussi dépêché sur les lieux des équipes
de scientifiques d'ingénieurs de
techniciens qui vont constater l'étendue
du désastre et envisager les mesures à
prendre pour enrayer sa progression
monsieur gérald harvey député de
jonquière et membre du conseil des
ministres est aussi venu sur les lieux
il a déclaré à la suite d'ailleurs du
premier ministre monsieur bourassa que
le gouvernement québécois mettait tout
en branle pour aider la population
frappée par cette catastrophe
cette catastrophe résultant d'une des
nuits des plus tragiques qu'un village
québécois est vécue en effet le conseil
des ministres a pris des mesures
extraordinaires pour venir en aide à la
population sinistrée
il a d'abord confié la direction et la
coordination des secours et de
l'activité policière à l'inspecteur
boisvert de la sûreté du québec à
chicoutimi la concentration de ses
pouvoirs entre les mains d'un seul homme
vise une plus grande efficacité dans les
opérations de surveillance et de secours
il a de plus confié au ministère des
affaires sociales le soin des personnes
déplacées et il a chargé le ministre des
affaires municipales de fournir la
petite municipalité de saint jean
vianney les moyens financiers et
techniques nécessaires à son relèvement
le terrain qui s'est écroulé et est le
plus redoutable qui fit au québec
d'après une étude que les géologues la
rochelle chagnon et lefebvre ont publié
l'an dernier
ces spécialistes ont même déterminé
qu'un siècle avant l'arrivée de jacques
cartier souhaitant 14 130 impasse
d'écoulement terrain c'est un produit à
cet endroit et bien d'autres un signe de
tangi s'ils sont manifestées au cours
des temps et tout récemment soit le 20
avril
un affaissement de 200 mille pieds
carrés de terrain est survenu sur la
propriété de monsieur pitt blackburn
environ un demi mille de l'agglomération
maintenant engloutis cet avertissement
avait effrayé quelques familles des
environs mais pas au point de susciter
une véritable prise de conscience du
danger ni de la part de la population ni
de celle des pouvoirs publics
de toute façon on était loin de
soupçonner que cet incident était le
signe avant-coureur de la catastrophe
qui vient de survenir un géologue du
gouvernement monsieur jean yves gagnon
exprimé l'avis que la tragédie a pu être
causée par une secousse sismique
enregistrée hier soir pour sa part l
ingénieur de l'université du québec
monsieur jean vallée que j'ai rencontrés
sur les lieux explique le phénomène à sa
façon
[Musique]
selon attentes monsieur vallée
où
m
[Musique]
d'abord on appelle ça un glissement de
terrain dans une argile sensible au
remaniement
qu'est ce qui peut causer ça c'est que
durant le printemps la fonte des neiges
et les pluies vont élever la table dos
d'un sol le niveau des lots qu'on trouve
dans les sols en général maintenant ça
cause des pressions hydrostatique plus
élevé que la normale
et ce qui affaiblit considérablement
l'argile en question à des profondeurs
assez
gan qui veut dire qu'une tragédie de ce
genre peut se produire à bientôt 33 ans
il s'en est déjà produit dans la
province de québec comme saint-joachim
de tourelles à nicolet qui est
exactement le même genre de catastrophe
si on peut-on les prévenir
on peut difficilement les prévenir
à moins que qu'ils aient qui se produit
des glissements de petits glissements
quelques jours avant les glissements
catastrophe et est ce que ça ne s'est
pas produit si je crois
qui a eu un petit glissement il ya une
quinzaine de jours mais je suis pas
certain de cette affirmation là que les
simplement entendu dire de la part d'un
sinistre y quinquis n'est quelques jours
ces produits qui a été signalé un
ingénieur et une annonce pour commencer
est ce qu'il ya ici quelqu'un qui a une
passe pour pouvoir pénétrer à faire
rayonner
alors madame marquis a déjà avec l
unique
cependant cette équipe qu'on l'a
renforcée je crois comprendre qu'ici la
nacelle actuellement nous avons nombre
de personnes qui sont venues offrir
leurs services
lesquels sont à 2000 personnes évacuées
ont été conduites au centre commémoratif
presse à kénogami la la croix rouge avec
la collaboration du ministère des
affaires sociales et le concours de la
population des environs s'est occupé de
nourrir de loger de vêtir ces personnes
ces familles dépourvues désemparés les
administrations municipales de la région
en d'autre part conjuguer leurs efforts
pour organiser une campagne de secours
pour les sinistrés les organisateurs de
cette campagne ont invité toutes les
familles désireuses d'y contribuer à le
faire sous la forme de leur choix les
porte-parole de compagnies d'assurance
ont d'autre part expliqué que les
risques encourus par les glissements de
terrain ne sont entièrement pas assurée
les immenses dégâts subis soit par
l'effondrement de maisons la menace qui
pèse sur bien d'autres demeurent ainsi
que la dévaluation que subira forcément
tout le petit village est prouvée reste
donc à la charge de ces malheureux
habitants leur avenir repose sur leur
volonté de relèvement sur leurs
ressources qui était déjà fort modeste
et sur l'aide qui pourra leur parvenir
du gouvernement de sociétés et de
particuliers
quoi qu'il en soit les conséquences
d'une nuit tragique hypothéqueront
durement à l'avenir d'un petit village
québécois qui avait vécu jusqu'ici dans
la tranquillité cette nuit d'horreur
s'est déroulée dans les ténèbres
profonde car dans cet écoulement où tous
seront paix avance engloutir le courant
électrique manquer si ce n'est pour
incendier un poteau une maison des
amoncellements de débris avec des
montagnes de gleiss ont glissé jusque
dans
saguenay en portant un pont sur la chip
chat c'est sur ce tableau désolant que
le jour s'est levé un jour qui devait
être bien triste et bien long en
présence de son gouffre et des menaces
nouvelles qui pèsent sur elle la petite
population de saint jean vianney en
deuil et dépouillé déloger n'arrive pas
encore à prendre toute la mesure de son
cauchemar ici andré dufour à saint jean
vianney